the research that I'm doing at Carnegie
Mellon University concerns how to build
technologies that are socially aware
that is technologies that can sense the
social skills of the people that they're
interacting with that can engage people
in a social relationship and that can
ensure that that relationship is the
underpinning of the work that the
computer and the person do together the
importance of the research that I'm
doing is to ensure that in this
increasingly technological age we
maintain a focus on those aspects of
humanity that are most important to us
that we ensure that we don't lose the
social bonds between people and the
relationships that we build with one
another
which after all are what make us human
and so the technologies that I build
don't replace people they collaborate
with people they don't destroy people
they build relationships with people
[Music]
you